hi I got it I'm David and you tell me
I'm suave
today we're trying cheap less expensive
burritos
I love burritos
all burritos all delivery no Chipotle
burrito burrito down the street you need
it anywhere yo in the car class right
you know yeah
all-purpose name in the burritos
burritos definitely skipped breakfast
today too so maybe the traffic real fine
Falls coming on yeah I can't believe
we're doing this blindfolded I feel like
I've been kidnapped but my kidnappers
are really generous cuz they're gonna
give me burritos oh yes are you where
are you
I'm over here okay where are you I'm
over I'm also on this plate no salsa
situation yeah I wouldn't say it's cheap
I would just say it's affordable yeah
it's not like you're $2.00 Taco Bell
vino cheese burrito so it's a little
yeah I would say it's an average price
[Music]
got the plate okay I have a burrito
this is hefty came a little bit bigger
like a whole wheat tortilla instead of
white tortilla you know my first dog was
vegan burrito let's oh you already went
for it let me do the same I'm like
trying to extinct it it's gonna spill
it's not as it's not as a drive the last
one I think it's more expensive cuz I
definitely tasted like an avocado or
blocking in there oh I must say this one
it could surprise me and be the
expensive one just because I feel like
there's different ingredients more
vegetables or like cabbage or some other
little sauce or salsa in there but yeah
it doesn't seem super cheap to me I
don't like it I'd like to walk yeah
you're right if it is vegan then I can
go up in the price mm-hmm yeah it's
probably a cashew something saucer and
then yeah oh no I hate this burrito yeah
it's pretty bad still eat it though okay
yeah my college friend
this Taco Bell I was like yeah let me
say this like a Taco Bell or a frozen
burrito I mean it's very thick mm-hmm
it's just got you poor hello salsa on it
just trying to like dr. Hema making
something special because that's why I
mean I love talk about because of the
hot sauce right
not because of this stuff here it's like
hot sauce solid read o probably the
cheapest definitely the cheapest this is
the cheapest so this is number the
cheapest one the vegetable I'm gonna put
second and then the first one I'm just
gonna say it's the most expensive
because who knows maybe it came from
some classic place yeah first one was
middle what do you think I completely
agree with that second one I would say
is most expensive yep and then this one
cheapest this is definitely the cheapest
burrito first burrito I ate was the
middle one the second burrito I ate was
the most expensive and this last one was
definitely the cheapest I know boletos I
know burrito
this blindfold thing was definitely
definitely they kind of made a way like
wait yeah I mean I had to use other
things like like help it yeah usually it
burritos burrito
my favorite burrito was I think the
Chipotle burrito me too
I think that was also are you guys gonna
attack us for saying that even though it
wasn't the most expensive than the first
one if they just had like a little bit
of moisture like any salsa or like you
know maybe some guac or something I
think overall I would have liked that
one the most
yeah the second one was just a little
bit too like cabbage or something heavy
and you know talk about wonderful or
whatever but it wasn't 2 a.m. so it
wasn't you know my favorite because it's
just a classic pairing the flavors paper
beans rice meat yeah yeah can I get
burrito number one back because I'm
gonna take that to go yeah I'd like mine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]